here's the fun trigonometry problem let
ABC be a right triangle with hypotenuse
AC suppose m is the midpoint of AC a b
equals 6 and b m equals five then the
sine of angle BMC is equal to what
to work it out construct the
circumcircle of ABC since we have a 90
degree inscribed angle here this Arc
will be equal to 180 degrees so AC is
the diameter of the circle that means am
equals M C equals BM is the radius of
the circle so am equals M C equals BM is
equal to 5. now considering the entire
triangle ABC we have a 6 8 10 special
right triangle so BC is equal to eight
let's drop this perpendicular here
creating a similar triangle that means
these lengths are equal to four and this
length is equal to three we now have
these angles equal to Theta so the sine
of BMC is equal to the sine of 2 Theta
use the double angle formula
substituting for the sine and cosine and
we get the answer of 24 over 25.